campaign I would hurt
just kidding make me know that that God
they didn't get to see my dad all the
time like a guy back there played catch
with his son it was something about when
I put this hat off and make me feel like
Superman
it gives me power away well I'm with her
didn't Hillary Clinton think that that
phrase might might alienate a large part
of the population it took someone like
Kanye West of all people to put a bright
red hat on and say hey what about us
here he is back in August explaining why
the Maggie hat represents a lot more
than just supporting Trump represented
overcoming fear and doing what you felt
no matter what anyone said and saying
you can't bully me liberals can't bully
me and news can't bully me the hip-hop
community they can't believe me because
at that point if I'm afraid to be me I'm
no longer yay joining me now is Tucker
Carlson host of Tucker Carlson tonight
and author of The New York Times number
one bestseller the ship of fools just
knocked Bob Woodward off the number one
spot on the New York Times bestseller
list
Tucker first of all I'm so happy that I
know you congratulations thank you and
when I was going through some tough
times in the last year you were like
among the first people who reached out
to me and you're just such a you know
you're a best-selling author you're a
top TV host but people have to know this
about Tucker you're also just a really
good person which in Washington DC
sometimes it's hard to find so well I'm
not a good person but I've certainly
been attacked so I have deep sympathy
for anybody including Kanye West who I
know nothing about I'm not interested in
yeah I just I feel for people who were
all of a sudden getting it from
everybody yeah yeah so yeah and I saw
your show last night where you talked
about the issue of fathers yes and
missing fathers in entire segments of
America and that he was he was talking
about that and look he's not a political
person he's not gonna speak and pundit
terms he's gonna speak the way he's
gonna speak and again it's not my musics
not my thing nor is it yours
but that was an interesting mom Maury
said the masculine presence in a family
is so important and she didn't speak to
me it was because she was a woman but it
was because she how she was portraying
her campaign
well Epps and he's absolutely right I
mean the Democratic Party is anti
masculinity and anti father they have to
be that's their base and that's just
true and they have been for a long time
and not everyone in the Democratic Party
but the leadership of the party is I
mean Aska we think that was very simple
I've done it actually say is it better
all things being equal million
exceptions to every rule but in general
is it better for kids to grow up with
the dad at home and they won't say it
yeah I know it's true and by the way I
grew up for part of my child in a
single-parent home it was great I'm not
attacking anybody I'm just saying like
if you can't say that then you're lying
and everyone knows you're lying and he
just kind of called them out into his
stream-of-consciousness way and I think
we should not attack him for that David
Gergen one of her close friends on CNN
yesterday said the following let's watch
is that what's going on with some of the
men in this country and their
relationship to Trump is being for Trump
make them feel more masculine I just
don't know the answer to that but boy
they were sure and overcome of it and
that's in that session in other words a
the masculinity the toxic masculinity
it's a it's a brutal type of being
masculine to be aligned with Trump I
mean Dave Dave's doing the best he can
I'm not going to attack him right okay
but the truth is that time the meal
that's that's we're good I feel bad for
him but that's real men feel that they
can't be men and that's not a talking
point about a men's movement guy or
whatever but if you had a movement that
was against toxic femininity or toxic
homosexuality you would say you're
attacking people for how they inherently
are right and you shouldn't do that
because it's mean and actually it hurts
kids when you do that and yet we send
six de grand a year to these stupid
schools these colleges that have entire
departments devoted to attacking men for
being men why are we putting up with his
garbage if you have a son this is a huge
threat to him if you have a daughter who
is she gonna marry I mean these are not
my questions they're central questions
now
your book has the interesting thing
about Tucker's book it's such a great
read it's about the elites both on the
right and the left but in your ship of
fools is Lindsey Graham and Mitch
McConnell and both of them were critical
absolutely
pushing Cavanaugh over the they did a
great job this week and I think anybody
who believes in fairness should be
grateful to them and I am we haven't
gotten the wall yet though Tucker
which is not a small thing and by the
way when Republicans you know face
difficulty in the midterms maybe it's
because the party ran on building a wall
not on an abstract wall if you're a
metaphorical wall but like on a physical
wall and then they sort of give the
finger to their voters like yeah well
you know wall it's kind of stupid it's
like maybe this stupid it doesn't matter
if you tell me I'm getting a pony for
Christmas you better not give me a bag
of hair because I'm gonna be really
disappointed tell me about your daily
life
oh you wake up give me their - give me
your time like if you had to just drop
in to Tucker Carlson's life when you
wake up in the morning it is
approximately what time I wake up around
7:30 or 8:00 okay and then what the
first thing usually die wife wakes you
up every morning with a cup of coffee
she goes for a run she comes back she
gets back in bed with me with the dogs
yeah sit and do email I talked to her
for a couple hours I really try and get
all my work done sitting in bed in the
morning and then like Churchill except
he doesn't have email okay so yeah and I
work on the email and I talked to a
million different people I don't go to
lunch typically I go into work do a ton
of writing mostly it's a writing job
yeah and then show ends and I go out to
dinner okay my beloved nephew tonight so
how many dogs are in bed with you at
night and any given time - two spaniels
Megan Dave okay so and is there at the
top of the bed are they always at the
foot of the bed do they make their way
up this is very controversial question
so all four of our kids have gone so
we're like the parody of the people were
very focused on their space okay good
but one I think is basically mine and my
wife disputes that and then the smaller
Spain on the sub spaniel yeah
the reserved spaniel yeah is more loyal
to now the dogs are they hunting dogs
both of them Ronnie so bird dogs you go
Beauford what do you know
pheasant quail chucker you know anything
yeah I'm not a huge man bow hunter I go
shoot pigs what's wrong
mostly I grew up bird hunting soil how
about a tennis ball they take that take
a tennis ball they come fishing with me
a lot they're my fish you know they're
fishing to attract dogs Tucker I'm so I
miss it proud of you sounds
condescending I'm so happy for you
Tucker is one opens ever asked me but
she just asked me a killing I said that
on TV I'm embarrassed no because this is
the you're like my brother so Tucker
Carlson ship of fools get this book it
is phenomenal it actually you trace the
elites on the left and right how they
tried to steer America into one
direction that people actually took it
and said nah we're gonna go into a
different direction
Tucker congratulations you're such a
great thing they say will you come on my
show next week done okay alright can I
come on your show next time anything
okay I'll walk over that studio
all right Tucker congratulations again
get this book phenomenal great stocking
stuffer early shopping for Christmas